yeah I think one of the criticism
especially that the White House is very
sensitive to is that Singapore was vague
there wasn't much specifics agreed apart
from maybe the return of prisoners and
American soldiers killed in the Korean
War
and here we go this is the handshake
between Trump and Kim see if we can hear
what they're saying
big smiles first time they've met in
since Singapore in June they look they
look pretty comfy
coming back
so good enough for me now
[Music]
[Music]
but and there was still the tea that's
still removed from their very very past
period from the outside but however we
have been able to overcome all the
obstacles and here we are today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well I wanted to say it's an honor to be
with Chairman Kim it's an honor to be
together in really a country Vietnam
where they've really rolled out the red
carpet and they've they're very honored
to have us and it's great to be with you
we had a very successful first summit I
felt it was very successful
and some people would like to see okay
satisfied you satisfied we want to be
happy with what we're doing but I
thought the first summit was a great
success and I think this one hopefully
will be equal or greater than the first
and we made a lot of progress and I
think the biggest progress was our
relationship is really a good one
[Applause]
thank you all very much we appreciate it
we've got dinner and then we have some
big meeting scheduled for tomorrow and
we'll see you I guess it's a news
conference at some point during the day
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you all very much we appreciate it
we're gonna go dinner and then we have
some big meeting scheduled for tomorrow
and we'll see you I guess it's a news
conference at some point during the day
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you all very much we appreciate it
and we're gonna got dinner and then we
have some big meeting scheduled for
tomorrow and we'll see you I guess it's
a news conference at some point during
the day thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you all very much we appreciate it
we've got dinner and then we have some
big meeting scheduled for tomorrow and
we'll see you I guess a news conference
at some point during the day thank you
very much